technology has changed things but people
have been sharing things for thousands
of years how do we talk about one
product versus another
can we get people talk about our stuff
our products and our ideas
why do we share content online or
products that we use
videos that go viral on the web we say
oh you know they got lightning in a
bottle i think we have this notion
that it's random that it's luck but it's
not there's really a science behind why
people talk we see the same six
factors social currency triggers emotion
public practical value and stories each
of those is a psychological driver of
why we talk
why we share and leads all sorts of
stuff to catch on do these six
currencies apply to every aspect of life
we've come across some of these ideas in
some of our life but
rarely do we make the connection across
different domains of life
is the internet has changed something
because the psychology doesn't
necessarily change there are lots of
great products and services that we've
never heard of
how does one uh go about changing
anyone's mind
rather than pushing people really
thinking about change a different way
and changing the strategy we use to
change minds is it also applied to
politics does it apply to
religions why some religions do better
than others obama ran on hope
inspiration trump ran on anger and
anxiety
both of them use high arousal emotions
and use that to drive action
we don't have to be the best
communicator to win
good story is a powerful thing
[Music]
my guest today is jonah berger who's
written multiple books
uh one called contagious that i read in
2013 when it came out i think i had our
entire salespeople
read it and write about it then he wrote
a second book called the invisible
influence and his latest one that came
out you see it in the back of the screen
where he's sitting at the catalyst
yellow and we'll talk about that as well
now he is a professor
at wharton uh school of university of
pennsylvania which is where our
president went
and he got his degree at stanford and
the major is
in human judgment and decision making in
2002 which is
fascinating to get a degree in that
because you can use that in every aspect
of your life
we're going to talk about marketing
viral marketing how you can be more
influential
and hopefully he'll have some uh tips
that you can implement
right away to your life and to your
business having said that
jonah thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment thanks so much
for having me
so so at what point did you say i want
to get a degree in human judgment like
how does that even take place
you know originally i thought i would
become an environmental engineer
i wanted to bridge sort of science and
society
i went to college taking classes in that
space sort of thinking about
uh you know technology hard sciences
research experimentation
statistics came across the social
sciences
fell in love with them and have spent a
career sort of applying
the tools of hard science
experimentation data analysis statistics
to social science problems and to better
understand human behavior
now it's pretty cool because that part i
mean pretty much what a business person
does
is that your human human judgment
decision making
and i know you've been advised you've
advised a number of startup
early stage startups you've consulted
for google
apple vanguard general mills gates
foundation a number of different places
which is pretty impressive to have that
kind of a background
but my question for you would be your
your first book came out in 2013.
from you leaving college to 2013 what
did you do professionally
yeah so i've had some work experience
but i spent a good amount of time
getting a phd
so i also got a phd in marketing
actually from the stanford graduate
school of business
uh and then started wharton in 2007.
uh so had a first six years at wharton
doing research and other things before
the first book came out and
uh you know it changed my life that book
a little bit uh i'm an academic at heart
love academic research always have
um but you know that book is out and got
you know 35 languages
half a million copies around the world
and uh since then i've gotten a chance
to talk to all sorts of companies and
organizations about marketing
about the challenges they're wrestling
with about getting products and services
and ideas to catch on i've learned a lot
about
different businesses and the way that
business is done in today's day and age
and it's been great to share some of
those learnings both with students in
the classroom as
well as through the books so so from
to 2013 i think it's fair to say a lot
of things changed in marketing in o2
facebook wasn't out youtube wasn't out i
think that's 04
06. i mean not not a lot was out yet in
o202 is still a myspace friendster era i
believe as it is
so so from your involvement as you're
going through this and you're learning
and
i'm curious as a college student going
to become a get your phd
how were professors adjusting their
teaching of marketing
advertising with all these new social
media uh
platforms that are coming out yeah so uh
you know first in college i read a book
uh that many people read uh around that
time called the tipping point
um and it's probably actually somewhere
in the shelf behind me right
right there still one of my favorite
books um and that book really catalyzed
my own journey um you know i said wow
this is really interesting it's
not sociology it's not psychology it's a
mix of all these different things and
really kind of encouraged me to start
studying why things catch on
there's a guy at stanford at the time
named chip heath who wrote
made to stick and decisive and a number
of other books i started doing research
with him
actually on why people share urban
legends so why rumors and urban legends
get shared
let me tell you no one's less fun to
have at a party than someone who studies
rumors in urban legends
you know someone will say oh this thing
happened to my cousin i'm like no no
it's not your cousin it's a rumor that's
been online forever
but it's really about the psychology of
why we share things less about sort of
you know online versus off
online does matter and technology has
changed things
but people have been sharing things for
thousands of years right it's not like
people waited for facebook to share word
of mouth
even now only about 10 percent of all
word of mouth is online
most of it's offline and so you know
really what i've studied is
why people share not you know online
versus offline or why they use facebook
versus instagram versus myspace which no
one uses anymore
but really more sort of the
psychological drivers of why we share
why do we talk about one product versus
another
why do we talk about you know one thing
we did this weekend rather than
something else
whether online or off what drives us to
share and how by understanding those
drivers
can we get people talk about our stuff
our products and our ideas
so why do we share i mean for the
simplest question why do we share
content online or products that we use
yeah you know i think we have this
notion uh that it's random
that it's luck that it's chance you know
we look at videos that go viral on the
web and we say oh you know
they got lightning in a bottle they just
must have must have gotten lucky
but it's not there's really a science
behind why people talk uh and and why
they share
um you know we've looked at thousands of
pieces of online content
tens of thousands of brands millions of
purchases across the united states and
around the world
again and again we see the same six
factors come up
in contagious i put those factors in a
framework called the steps framework
uh it stands for social currency
triggers motion
public uh practical value and stories
each of those is a psychological driver
of why we talk
why we share and leads all sorts of
stuff uh to catch on
can you mind unpacking each one of those
for some people maybe haven't read the
book contagious
sure yeah and so i'm happy to go into
depth one or two of them but uh quick
overview
uh you know social currency the better
something makes us look the more likely
we are to share it
right so we share i met a celebrity i
got promoted we don't share i got fired
and
you know something bad happened we
shared stuff that makes us look good
rather than stuff that makes us look bad
and so there the intuition is well how
can we make people look good by talking
about
us uh as as individuals we think a lot
about well how do we look
we think a lot less about how does that
person look when they talk about
us and so making others look good
triggers top of mind tip of tongue
right just like peanut butter reminds us
of jelly a lot of what we talk about
is based on what we're thinking about
and so triggers in the environment can
remind us to think of things and cause
us to talk about and share them
emotion when we care we share we don't
just share functional things we share
things that
make us feel and certain emotions
increase sharing and some actually
decrease it
public easy to see easy to imitate you
know i can see you wearing a nice sort
of shirt i can buy something similar
because i saw you wear it
but i can't imitate your stocks because
it's a lot harder to see you wearing
and so we imitate what we can see now we
can't see
practical values useful information uh
you know news you can use
tips tricks ways to be better off and
then last but not least is stories
right often we don't just pass on
information we share information as part
of a broader narrative
and so using something called trojan
horse stories to carry
our ideas along for the ride jonah how
much of this
applies to is it evergreen to every
industry or is it specific to just
business meaning does this apply to uh
years ago we're not playing magic cards
all of a sudden magic cards every kid is
playing or years ago people weren't
using what was those
pokey pokemon not pokemon what was those
the round things that you would hit them
that you when the other ones are jumping
i don't know what that was but all of a
sudden everybody had them you know you
just kind of have to have one and
you know is it also applied to politics
does it apply to
religions why some religions do better
than others how much do these six
currencies apply to every aspect of life
you know what's interesting um is the
internet has changed some things right
it's allowed information it's moved
faster and easier than ever before
but let's take the principle of social
currency we like looking good to others
we share things that make us look good
rather than things that make us look bad
well that didn't start because the
internet started
right i mean think about a caveman right
you know caveman would
talk to one another being don't don't
eat that it's poisonous you know look at
this thing i caught
we've been sharing things that make us
look good forever right in the 1950s
people shared what made them look good
in the 60s the same thing and so
what i love about studying psychology
behavioral science rather than a
specific domain or vertical
is the psychology doesn't necessarily
change the way we're built
it may ebb a little bit and flow a
little bit based on technology and other
things but
that underlying driver of why we do what
we do is true across
domains you know you mentioned some of
the organizations i've worked with i've
certainly worked with
big consumer packaged goods companies
and technologies but i've also worked
with b2b companies i've also worked with
political campaigns i've also worked
with
you know people that want to change
their kids behavior the way the
education system works and so
the principles are very much the same
how we apply the principles differ
we have to understand how to apply them
in a given context you know what
what makes a 50 year old business
executive look good is different than
what makes a
15 year old girl look good right they
they care about how they look
different things make them look good but
that principle of caring how they look
and sharing things that make them look
good
is true across domains based on the
amount of research you've done i mean
you gotta now what two decades of
research in this space maybe even more
than that because two thousand
more than two decades of research in the
space uh
your your experience i'm curious what
wins a great product okay a great
marketing idea
a great sales team a great culture or
great storytelling so you got a great
product but you suck at the rest
does that do better than a great
marketing idea great sales team great
culture great storyteller
i'm curious to know what you're going to
say based on all the different case
studies you've read and
experienced personally yourself yeah so
that's a that's a tough one to answer
i'll start by ruling out what i
i don't think is the winner right so
we'll go uh you know
having a great product is certainly
important uh it's hard to win with a
terrible product
but there are lots of great products and
services that we've never heard of
crazy right i work i work with so many
you know early stage technology
companies would say something online
we've built this thing that no one has
ever built before
and i say well that's interesting but
who needs it and they go no no you don't
understand
no one's ever done this before and i say
okay but who wants this what need does
it fill what customer is going to
going to want to change their behavior
to do this and it's not just about the
product being good right
it's about everything else that we build
around it
it's certainly important to have a good
sales team it's certainly important to
have good culture and good organization
but i would say a good story i would say
a good story i've had to pick one of
those trumps all of them
right a good story is a powerful thing
a good story helps change minds helps
drive action
helps propagate your message because a
good story can be memorable and
told again and so that can really be
much more important than any of those
other things you know you have a great
sales team what wonderful about word of
mouth
is it turns your customers into the
largest sales team you've ever had right
rather than having
you know five people that are great
salesmen if you can turn
all your customers into advocates
suddenly now they're all doing the work
for you rather than you having to try to
convince someone
oh it's great let me tell you why and i
know we'll talk about the catalyst in a
few minutes and the challenge of
changing minds but you know
it's really hard to change someone's
mind if you're self-interested people
know that you as a salesperson are
trying to change their mind
but if their friend says hey i bought
that product it was great if their
colleague says you know i listened to
that podcast it was wonderful they're
going to be much more likely to change
so
word of mouth is much more powerful than
traditional advertising and
and much more powerful than great sales
people yeah you know i don't do what you
do professionally i i
we we uh created a video back in october
of 2015 called life of an entrepreneur
in 90 seconds
okay and this video originally we
uploaded it on youtube on october 30th
uh and we were so excited oh my gosh
this thing's gonna at that point you
know my youtube channel probably has
thousand subscribers 500 subscribers
nothing's really going on
and facebook we i may have two or three
thousand uh facebook fans
so the video goes out on youtube titled
best motivational video of 2015.
okay and you know obviously it's a very
a
unique title we gave it right i mean no
one's ever come up with that title
before
and in 24 hours that thing gets 2 500
views total flop right nothing crazy
so then it's october 31st it's friday
it's halloween i'm about to take my kids
to the mall
i decided to upload it on facebook uh
with the title life of an entrepreneur
90 seconds
okay and i said on the below tag an
entrepreneur we went
i didn't even think about it came back
two and a half hours later i look at it
says 300
000 views i'm like what it's got to be a
mistake
i go to sleep i wake up in the morning
it's got 10 million views in 12 hours
every single one of my company websites
are down
i have thousands of emails and messages
coming in all over the place
saying this video resonated with me it
connected with me etc etc i cannot
believe what it says
but you're right it is a form of
storytelling that it connected with the
audience
when they see a story and they say you
know what and then from there it did
change
the way where customers started wanting
to tell the story and next thing you
know 30 40 50 million views later in the
first 30 days
it's a completely different story so how
does one who's sitting there for
yourself
when you watch people online because i
bet you're probably
looking at a lot of influencers and
you're looking at different marketing
and brand but specifically in this area
of an influencer so think about
i'm a person that runs a business i run
a decent business i do 510 million a
year
but i'm really trying to crack this
you know influencer marketing thing for
myself i want to be an influencer people
don't know me i may have a
few hundred people that follow me or a
few thousand people that follow me but i
haven't had it yet
what direction what are my first five
moves that i need to make i know the six
steps you just gave me here right now
what the triggers are
but what are the first five steps i take
to say okay
here's how i go out and create a name
for myself and i become a voice
in my space as an influencer how does
one go about doing that
yeah i mean i would start by focusing
less on the technology
and more on the psychology right more on
why people talk and share who are my
existing customers
you know what do they like about me what
are the stories that they may or may not
be telling
about me already and how can i build
from from there right
if we don't understand the people that
we're trying to reach if we don't
understand
why people find our business or ideas uh
attractive
it's going to be very hard to become
successful and
and just to be clear you know lots of
people do some things by luck right you
know once in a while sure
you know something that they do on one
out of a thousand things
will hit but if we understand why that
hit why it was successful
we can engineer it to be more success we
did a study a few years ago
where we analyzed thousands of articles
from one of the largest newspapers in
the united states
we did text analysis natural language
processing to understand what emotions
those articles evoked
and we can say look you know you add
more emotion to a
an appeal for example an online video an
article you're 20 to 30 percent more
likely to make something like the most
emailed list right
it's not just saying here's an example
of a hit and here's an example of a
failure
but let's codify by looking at the
underlying data or mechanisms of how
these things work
essentially a recipe for for success
right just like
you you know you understand how to cook
cakes you know what to add into the mix
so that it tastes better
we can say look you use this recipe and
we can make whether it's our content
online
or our messages offline go viral and i
know there's a tendency to want to focus
online right a lot of attention today
online
but i would say don't just think about
online also think about offline
it's great if a video goes viral but you
don't just want that video to go viral
you want the emails and the calls and
those other things that you got to
happen
that's what you care about you don't
care if a million people clicked on
something
you care well do they watch that thing
does that thing change their behavior
does it
lead them to become a customer or client
or interested
in what i'm doing and so i think at the
end of the day too many people focus on
the number of views
their content gets online and not
whether it's actually moving the needle
in in terms of action people share a
number of things online that they don't
even watch and
many things online even someone has a
lot of followers don't necessarily get
attention
and so that's why i love offline what's
wonderful about a one-to-one
conversation
is that person's listening right when
you have a one-to-one conversation that
person is listening to you
when you post something online sometimes
the people are listening
but sometimes they may be doing two or
three other things while they're
watching your content
and so you want to make sure yes it's a
great way to spread messages
but don't only think online think
offline as well
and make sure to be customer focused
right make sure to be focused on the
consumer the customer you're hoping to
reach
and understanding what drives them can
you tell me what you mean by uh
face-to-face one-on-one instead of
online oh just offline word of mouth
right i mean i think you know sometimes
we think about word of mouth we think
well you must be talking about social
media
90 of word of mouth is face to face
know spouses talking to one another over
the dinner table at least pre-covered
times going out and grabbing a drink
with friends
regular everyday interactions not as
exciting
uh not as you know doesn't have a
million views but equally important for
actually driving action at the end of
the day
yeah i know in your book you talk a lot
about the videos examples you give and
how many views they got you gave the
example of that one girl who friday
friday friday
it's 145 million views and the parents
spent four thousand dollars uh
to uh put this video together and uh it
ends up being one of the most hated
videos of the year you talk about that
you talk about the other video where
uh this guy's selling his blender and he
puts the phone in there and it turns
black
and hey this is my blender i still have
another iphone these videos made a lot
of you said seven hundred percent i
think is the number you said
yeah where that one company went up
simply because that uh the video that
came up that
and the reason why i'm sharing this part
with you a lot of entrepreneurs they'll
message me and they'll say pat
you know the dollar shave club company
that sold four billion dollars
you know which ad i'm talking about
where he's walking through with the blow
dryer and all this other stuff and
you know what screw it i'm gonna buy a
dollar shave i'm gonna join the dollar
shave club i'm gonna buy the membership
here and i'm gonna go out there and do
xyz for somebody jonah who is not
great at creating these types of
storytelling like okay you'll sit there
and tell somebody
hey let's let's come up with a story who
needs to be in the room
to come up with these stories meaning
yeah do i do
is your strategy like if somebody hires
you
do you go in a room with five people and
you ask a series of questions that leads
to answers and then eventually you say
well if this is the motive you want if
this is a call to action you want where
do we want them to end up and why should
they buy this and why are people liking
this
what what is the step-by-step process
and who's in the room
that can help bring out these ideas and
what are some of the questions that's
being asked i know it's a
pretty loaded question three questions
within one but i'm curious to know
the actual steps of how someone can go
about doing this
yeah and so um uh it's tough to do this
in five minutes but i'll give you a
sense of it and i'm
uh you know this is the type of thing i
do with all sorts of clients but
i think i start always we start always
by saying well imagine you could script
a conversation
between an existing customer or
potential customer what would that
person say
right very often people say i want more
word of mouth i want people to talk
about me
rarely do they think about well actually
what am i hoping someone says
right and in particular they're not
going to talk about 10 different things
if they could talk about one thing about
me
what would that thing be i call that a
kernel right that's often what a story
is built around what is the kernel the
attribute
the value proposition the differentiator
what would you want them to talk about
you have great service
uh you know for that blender for example
that video shows how powerful the
blender is doesn't talk about how much
vendor cost doesn't talk about where you
can find it all it does it shows one
thing how powerful it is
and it does it really well and so before
you can build a really good story
you have to think essentially what's the
moral that i want that story to tell
you know think back to a story like the
boy who cried wolf right
that's a great story it's a highly
engaging story at the end of that story
you learn that lying is a bad idea
that's the moral of that story
now if i'm a brand i can say well let me
tell a really engaging story
but if i pick the wrong story and it
gets across the wrong moral
no one's learning what i want them to
learn right if they remember the story
but they don't remember me
if they remember me but they don't
remember why they should work with me
it's not going to be a beneficial story
there are lots of ads and videos that go
viral that don't necessarily move the
needle for brands
because the key is not just hey i like
this story or even i remember this story
but the story teaches me something just
like a moral of a parable
teaches me something that's then going
to drive me to action so i start with
that moral or that kernel what is that
thing
that you want someone to communicate and
then right if you're not a great
storyteller no problem
talk to your existing customers what are
the stories that they're already telling
talk to your salespeople what are the
stories that they're already telling
often you don't have to generate your
own stories all you have to do is
surface some of the stories that are out
there already
right even if you have a five person
sales organization you have 100
customers
you know there's at least 20 30 maybe
even 40 stories that are out there
already
some of them are better than others if
you just capture some of those stories
you figure out which of them seem to be
working already then you can almost ask
act like a hub of a hub and spoke and
push it out to the rest of the network
but you don't have to come up with it
yourself you don't have to be creative
you have to be strategic
and identify the really good stories and
i do lots of workshops both in you know
executive education at wharton and with
clients
where people always want to jump to the
end right they want to go to the punch
line of the store and everybody's going
to laugh and it's going to be great
but i often ask them to stop step back
and say okay what did someone learn from
that story
and they go i don't know it's a funny
story if you don't learn anything from
the story
right you're not your job is not the
entertainment business we're not we're
not in the
necessarily as a company right if i'm
selling something i'm not in the
entertainment business
i'm in the business of selling that
thing if at the end of the day they
don't buy that thing maybe they enjoyed
my story
but it's not going to move the needle
and so we have to make sure the story
the moral of that story the kernel of
the story
gets across what we want it to very a
very big point by the way let's talk
about your latest book the catalyst
yeah so how does one uh go about
changing anyone's mind
you know so i'll tell you a quick story
so contagious comes out and as i
mentioned sort of changed my life a
little bit before that i was an academic
i spent 90 of my time doing research and
teaching
10 of the time doing you know consulting
and speaking here and there
contagious comes out i thought it would
do okay it ends up doing much better
than i ever
ever imagined so you know half million
copies 35 languages around the world and
suddenly you know everyone from the
googles and the facebooks and the nikes
to small startups are calling for help
and so
i got to learn a lot about how business
is done
in today's day and age and i realized
that a lot of people had the same
problem
which is they all had something that
they wanted to change right so sales
people wanted to change the client's
mind and marketers wanted to change
consumer behavior
leaders wanted to transform
organizational culture and employees
wanted to change their boss's mind
you know startups wanted to change
industries and non-profits wanted to
change
the world but change is really hard
often we push and we pressure and we
cajole we give more reasons we add more
facts and figures
we think if i just make one more phone
call if i just make one more powerpoint
presentation
people change but often they don't right
often it's like
nothing at all happened and so the
question i started asking myself is
could there be a better way
and i started doing some interviews i
started interviewing you know great
business leaders
startup founders great sales people i
started interviewing hostage negotiators
and substance abuse counselors
i started interviewing parenting experts
anyone who was trying to change
minds in one situation or another and i
started to realize that there was a very
different approach out there
rather than pushing people really
thinking about change a different way
and changing the strategy we use to
change minds
and so what did you find so instead of
pushing people what was it yeah so you
know think for a moment imagine you're
in a room
and there's a chair in the middle of the
room and you want to move that chair
what do we often do we push that chair
right we push it in the right direction
we think it will go that works really
well for physical objects
and so we think the same thing is true
of people i push someone they'll go in
the right direction
the problem is when you push people as
we all know anyone who has a
three-year-old or anyone's tried to sell
anything knows
they push back rather than just going
along sliding across the floor they
think about all the reasons why they
don't want you to do
why they don't want to do what you're
doing and so rather than think about
what could i get someone to change
what you find great catalysts do is they
ask a slightly but importantly different
question
why hasn't that person changed already
what are the barriers or
obstacles that are in their way that are
preventing them from changing
and how can i mitigate those barriers
it's it's almost like if you've ever
been parked on an incline right you get
a
you get in your car you turn your key in
the ignition you stick your foot on the
gas
if the car doesn't go you just think you
need more gas more pushing will get it
to go
but we rarely go wait there's that
parking brake that's depressed right
that's getting in the way and so what
the book is all about is well what are
the five
common parking brakes that come up again
and again those five common obstacles
that get in the way
and how by mitigating those obstacles
removing those barriers can we change
anything so what are those five
yeah so similar to contagious i put them
in a framework uh the first
is reactants the second is endowment the
third is distance
the fourth is uncertainty and the fifth
is corroborating evidence
together they spell the word reduce
which is exactly what great catalysts do
they don't push harder they don't
provide more facts and more reasons and
more information
instead they reduce the barriers to
change they identify those parking
brakes or those obstacles
and they mitigate them so react
in in what's the second one uh reactants
endowment endowment distance uncertainty
uh and corroborating evidence
corroborating evidence so
is it is it almost like you're gathering
intel is that a form of gathering intel
is that what you would say
a little bit you know what i found is
when you often ask people
why a change didn't happen they don't
know so you talk to a sales person you
say
well why didn't the customer or client
buy something i don't know you know i i
gave my pitch i gave them all the
reasons why they should do something
and they didn't change we're so focused
on the outcome that we want to achieve
the thing we want to get to we rarely
stop to go well
why hasn't that person changed what's
the barrier that's getting
in their way you know when we go to the
doctor's office imagine you went to the
doctor's office and the doctor the first
thing they said was let me put a cast on
your leg
you go wait a second you don't even know
what the problem is we do the same thing
all the time right anytime we're trying
to change someone we focus on why they
should change
rather than starting by going well hold
on let me understand you well enough
so i understand why you haven't changed
already so i can figure out what those
barriers are and and mitigate
them got it so you might have taken a
moment and breaking down these five
things
individually even if it's 20 seconds a
piece sure
yeah so uh i have a three-year-old at
home
so i'm very familiar with the idea of
reactants but the simple idea of
reactants is
when we push people they push back right
when we tell someone what they should do
whether it's go to bed eat your
vegetables
buy this product or you know wear a mask
whenever we tell people to do something
they often push back they often don't
want to do it and so it's all about how
we can give people their freedom and
their autonomy back and encourage them
to feel like they have choice
endowment is the simple fact that we
have the status quo bias we're attached
to whatever we're doing already we buy
the same products use the same
services go to the same place for
vacation uh you know shop at the same
grocery store
when we were driving to work save the
team drive to work every day
we do what we've done in the past
because it's easier and so we have to
figure out how to people
get people to let go of what they're
doing already make them realize that
what they've been doing isn't as safe as
we think we think doing nothing is
costless
doing nothing is often actually very
expensive we need to make people realize
that
a distance simply often when we ask for
too much people say well no way
when you ask for something that's too
far from where they are in the moment
they're unwilling to listen
and so we have to shrink the size of our
asks and manage distance
a little bit a little bit better
uncertainty anytime there's something
new
there's uncertainty involved they're
switching costs to buy a new product use
a new service it costs us something to
do it
and even if the old thing isn't perfect
at least we know what the problems are
with new things we don't know what the
problems are and that uncertainty that
fear of the unknown
often stems action and so we have to
alleviate uncertainty by
lowering the barriers to change and then
last but not least is corroborating
evidence
simple idea there is you know sometimes
when one person tells us something it's
not enough to tip the scales sometimes
we need
multiple sources we need more proof you
know if someone says that you have a
tail there's an old adage someone says
you have a tail you laugh
if five people say you have a tail you
turn around to take a look
simple idea right providing more proof
from multiple others can often tip the
scales to drive action
so essentially testimonials as the last
one
a little bit but i'd even say more
thinking about what are the right
sources of evidence and how can we
concentrate that evidence to make people
more likely to take action meaning
credibility like a a
source with a lot of credibility
credibility behind it is that what
you're saying
i'd even say the following even if
someone's very credible tells you they
like something
that's one piece of evidence but they
can tell you they like it until they're
blue in the face that's still one
person's opinion
what you're still trying to do is go
okay and i know you like it and you may
be a very credible source but well i
like it
right what is the fact that you like it
mean for for me
right there's sort of a translation
going on a translation problem
and if there's always one person i can
always say well it's you you
like things you're a certain person but
if there's five people it's much harder
to go
wait if five people like it i'm probably
going to like it as well
particularly the more similar they are
to me and the more that evidence is
concentrated the more it's going to
drive action
jonah what what brands do you see that
do a great job at this and what brands
do you see that have made a mistake with
this are there examples you can share
with us
you know i i don't think of just brands
i think even of organizations as a whole
right so
think about the situation we're at the
moment with uh with covet right
and the coronavirus i'm you know the
government and public health
organizations did the same thing they've
done for decades
if they want people to do something tell
them to do it wear a mask you know if
they
want people not to do something you know
don't go grocery shopping stay at home
they told them not to do it
and the problem what that does is that
often induces reactants
right if someone tells you not to do
something even if you might be willing
to do it in the first place
the fact that they told you to do it
makes you less interested in doing it
don't don't tell me what to do
right we essentially have an
anti-persuasion radar where we want to
feel like we're making our own choices
if we feel like someone's selling us if
we feel like someone's trying to
persuade us
our defenses go up right that brick wall
goes up we ignore the message we avoid
it or even worse we counter argue we sit
there and think about
all the reasons why what that person is
suggesting is a bad idea
why it won't work right why it's not
going to be effective
and so instead we have to figure out how
to reduce reactants by allowing people
to make those choices for themselves
right so you know think about in the
health case right
rather than telling people well wear a
mask or don't do this you know instead
ask a question you could say something
like hey
you know imagine your uh child is around
or your elderly grandparent
would you want everyone else to wear a
mask well that person says yes
right then you can say something well
why aren't you wearing a mask at the
moment right
highlighting a gap between their
attitudes and their action
right not telling them what to do but
encouraging them to go wait a second
if i would want other people to do
something why aren't i
doing that thing or other things you
know i talk about providing a menu
essentially basically giving people
choice you know if you're in a meeting
sales meeting for example and you're
telling everybody hey this is what you
should do
this is the course of action you should
take everyone's sitting there
and they seem like they're listening but
really what they're doing is thinking
about all the reasons why what you're
suggesting
is not going to work it's going to be
too expensive of course you would say
it's good
you're the salesperson how are we going
to integrate this with our existing
solutions
you know they're basically doing doing
counter arguing if instead what great
sales people do great consultants do is
they give people a choice
they don't just give them one option
they give them multiple a or b
a b or c because what it does is it
shifts the role
of the listener now rather than sitting
there thinking about all the reasons why
they don't like what you're suggesting
instead they're sitting there going huh
which of these do i like better
which makes them much more likely to
pick one at the end of the meeting
because what you've done is you've
provided a menu you've given them that
freedom of choice and because they feel
like they're free to choose they're much
more likely to pick something
who who in your life was very good at
doing this to you
you know i've been asked this question
before um and what i think is very funny
is i don't think my friends
my colleagues or my spouse would say i'm
particularly persuasive
right they would they wouldn't go oh
jonah you know he's really great at
changing everyone's mind so hopefully
this book has helped me by learning
these techniques
become better at it because i think you
know often
we see these things in a particular
domain but we don't apply it as widely
as we could like reactants for example
right you know maybe we've tried that
with our kids where we say oh you know
telling them to put their pajamas on
isn't working telling them to eat their
vegetables isn't working
but saying do you want to put your
pajama top or your bottom on first you
want to eat your broccoli or your
chicken first
that does right we've come across some
of these ideas in some of our life but
rarely do we make the connection across
different domains of life and so
what i think has been needed about this
book is to see these tools in action
in so many different places and to start
using them more
in my own life as well i guess what i
was asking was who is good at doing this
to you
like a parent father mother who was who
was good at getting you to believe that
you're making the choice on the decision
you're making
uh you know i think uh i i think people
do this
uh often uh uh in in my life uh at least
in in one way or another they
um reduce uncertainty so you know uh
think about companies that have given
free shipping
uh a way to to encourage people to take
action like the
zappos of the world or think about
companies that use freemium like dropbox
or like pandora that
lower that upfront cost that get us to
try things they haven't focused on
reactants per se but they've certainly
alleviated
uncertainty is one thing they've they've
done quite well
um uh you know my brother in some ways
has done a good job with ass of his of
of shrinking distance and so
i think different people have used
different tools and it's been great to
bring them all together
very cool so let's talk about a couple
different things and then we'll wrap up
so
are you following any of the
presidential campaign
i have a little bit yes not heavily but
a little
who do you think is doing a better job
uh getting their message out there and
are you seeing
patterns that they're using that have to
do with both contagious
and catalyst yeah i mean i'll say
a couple things um you know contagious
came out
before the 2016 election so obviously i
couldn't talk about the 2016 election in
that book but
um if you look at both what obama ran on
and what trump ran on
um they ran on something very similar
though different in some ways uh
obama ran on hope inspiration trump ran
on anger
and anxiety both of them used high
arousal emotions
to drive people to share their message
and use that to drive action and that's
something i talked a lot about in
contagious right
often we think it's about functional
reasons in politics for example it's all
about the bills and the policy details
and all those things
but i think if the last elections have
taught us anything it's stories
emotional stories whether positive or
negative
as long as they're high arousal emotions
so anger and anxiety are not the same as
hope and inspiration
but both of them fire us up to take
action right
you know think about seeing a snake
right we get scared that fear motivates
us to take action run away
hope and inspiration excites us and
motivates us to take action and so
both candidates leverage that in
different but interesting ways
to motivate action i think you've seen
the same thing more recently right
where um you know biden who used to be a
very sort of policy person
is still talking about policy but
talking much more into stories
and emotional way trump has always
tended to talk in stories in terms of
stories and emotion and really
use that to rally uh his base and so i
think you're seeing both candidates
realize
particularly in today's day and age it's
not information
or policy proposals necessarily that
drive action
whether fortunately or unfortunately i
think often unfortunately
it's often stories and sound bites that
are packaged and
understand the fact that high arousal
motion drive sharing
that ultimately drive action what are
your thoughts with media
on on the direction media is taken on
how to either
change people's minds uh uh and
influence them to
you know think one way or another what
what role is media playing by
using some of these strategies that
you're talking about to get their
message out there are you seeing that
taking place
what i think is interesting is the media
is much more fragmented than it than it
used to be right so it used to be if you
wanted to change people's minds you know
the best thing you could do would be to
buy an ad on one of the major networks
because everybody would see it the
problem now first of all
nobody watches television very few
people watch television many fewer
people watch watch television
and even if they do there are now so
many different channels that people are
watching
uh that the audience is much more
fragmented and even if they're
theoretically watching a television
channel
they're probably also on their computer
they're probably also looking at twitter
or something else while they're doing it
and so the attention's not there that it
might have been in the past
what i think is so neat about social
media and if you really think about the
term of social media what it is at the
core is
everyone has their own media channel
right each of us has a set of followers
who
probably don't see everything that we
post but in some sense are tuning in to
to our
channel and so this fragmentation makes
it a lot harder for
one message to hit everyone at the same
time
that said sharing becomes even more
important
right because people are turning to
social because people are turning to
their peers for
their news and information sharing
becomes a much more important way than
traditional advertising to get a message
out there
not only traditional advertising much
more expensive than than word of mouth
which is free
but it's much less persuasive and so i
think we have to understand how word of
mouth works and we have to understand
how to change minds otherwise it's
really hard to get our ideas
get them out there goes back to you
talking about the power of one-on-one in
word-of-mouth marketing which is
you know a more important because if you
can win one-on-one if you can win
through word of mouth
you're gonna potentially be able to
compete with these guys that have the
bigger budgets to advertise on tv
and spend the tens of millions of
dollars they're doing it's almost like
the great equalizer with what's going on
today
if those that can learn on the one on
one side so here here's a here's another
question for you
uh going back to i asked it from you
earlier and we kind of went through
process of both your books now the
audience kind of has an idea what was
disgusting and uh
contagious and what was discussed in the
catalyst and my recommendation if you're
watching this
it's 1 100 of what he talks about in the
book so we're going to put the links
below for you to buy
i'll be very transparent with you guys
i've not read the catalyst
but i've read the contagious i don't
know how many times it's
a every marketer needs to read
contagious
and based on some of the other five
markers i need to go buy myself the
latest book which is the catalyst
but you know when you watch uh folks out
there who are storytelling
okay you'll see the rock who gets out
there and uh
a crisis is taking place and he has a
method of telling the story
that resonates with an audience okay you
see ben shapiro
different style you see candace owens
different style you see aoc completely
different style
you see aj low different style you see
these musicians these artists these
politicians these pundits
that are going out there telling their
stories
how do you see it where somebody else
can say i mean i guess the question i'm
trying to ask is
does somebody watch and say you know i
can't be like that person's style it
just doesn't fit my personality
i resonate with this person's style what
what does one do to match to the other
person's
uh style because sometimes you see
people are acting like you said earlier
when you said uh
i think in one of the videos you said
how
you saw one commercial where joe montana
was wearing skechers shoes and you said
i just don't believe you is joe montana
broke does he need to make money like
it just didn't make any sense and i
agree with you when i saw that i'm
i went to the state when i first um
watched that commercial of joe montana i
said
i just don't see joe asked skechers it
doesn't make any sense to me right yeah
so somebody money right how does one
align
their personality and style to the
messaging to be able to still make
impact and change people's minds
yeah i think this builds on something
you uh very nicely said before which is
um you know we don't have to be uh the
best communicator to win i think
some of us think you know oh i have to
be really persuasive person i have to be
you know very charismatic i have to be
all of those things and
to be a movie star you probably do you
know to be an elected official
you probably do to be a successful
business person you you don't have to be
those things right um you have to
understand
what your audience is interested in the
the ideas that they care about how they
process
information how their minds works
because you can tell a story let's say
you're a great storyteller you tell one
person that story
that person may go oh my god you're an
amazing storyteller but if the story
itself isn't amazing
they're not going to pass it on they'll
listen to you but to have the impact you
want to have
to have the multiplier you want to have
you've got to get other people
to tell your story and so think about a
joke teller for example some of us are
great joke tellers right
you go to a party someone tells a joke
everybody laughs but some jokes are so
powerful that regardless of who tells
them
the joke propagates right because it's
just a funny joke and so it's not the
messenger it's the message
and that's really i think one of the
main things i would i would take away
from the the stuff that i've written and
the work that i've done
right is not just being a great
communicator sure it's great if you're
really persuasive and confident and
charismatic
that's great but even if you're not if
you're shy if you're timid
you can still engineer great ideas by
building great messages
right great messages share themselves
when you get an audience excited about
an idea because that idea is so great
they'll go tell other people even when
you're not in the room and so if we're
charismatic sure the people in the room
will go oh my god that was great
but they'll do a terrible job of telling
other people about it because you're no
longer in the room
if the message itself is powerful it
leaves the room with those people and
shares itself
generation upon generation yeah i like
that great messages share themselves
that's a very powerful
statement you got to have a story for a
person who want to share your story
rather than you constantly telling your
story it's got to be shareable
uh final thoughts here before we wrap up
you know pandemic is
looking like it's coming to an end here
the cases are lower
that's our lower i'm in texas you know
restaurants are going back to 100 a lot
of them people are still wearing masks
to wear masks but
how much of an opportunity is there for
a small business owner
or an entrepreneur to use this as a way
to tell a story to get the customers to
want to come back to them
or even get new customers to come and
want to do business with them is there a
big opportunity today with storytelling
on regaining trust or gaining the trust
of new customers certainly i mean i
think um you know
as we've discussed a bit you know now is
a time of huge uncertainty
people hate uncertainty they want to do
the same thing again and again they've
been forced to change in almost every
area of their life
and while that's certainly difficult for
people and has been quite difficult
it's also an opportunity because people
have been forced to change they're
looking for new products
and services and brands you know if you
uh read some of the articles the trends
and what people are buying have been
amazing to see right you know
people are buying home gym equipment
then they're buying teaching equipment
for their kids
you know the next thing is supposed to
be i don't know outdoor fire pits as it
gets colder for for winter
and so people are saying i'm in an
unusual situation how do i deal with the
situation and they're looking to their
peers and others
to figure out what to do but what that
means is look if you're a smaller brand
if you're a smaller company or
organization
people haven't used you in the past now
is a great opportunity to get some more
traction
they're willing to open up to challenger
brands and organizations they haven't
worked with before
because it's a time of uncertainty but i
think we can turn that uncertainty into
opportunity
right i've seen lots of organizations
use to say hey free trial right
i know stuff your life's tough at the
moment money's a little tough free trial
free trial is great because it's going
to give people the experience to figure
out whether they like what you're doing
and then they'll they'll stick with you
right and so i think great brands are
great corporaties great organizations
are using this time not as one of
uncertainty
but by turning that uncertainty to
opportunity by knowing what people
need understanding those needs and
working to meet them
i'm certain anybody that's in business a
c-suite executive founder entrepreneur
sales person took a lot
away from took away a lot from today's
meeting with you uh jonah i appreciate
your time congrats on your success with
your books
and spending nearly 20 years going to
school studying everything that has to
do with human behavior marketing
i wish you nothing but the best and i'm
looking forward to reading many more
books of you to come in the future
awesome thanks so much for having me
take care bye
so first of all if you've never read the
book contagious i highly recommend it
we'll also put the link to both of his
books below for you to go out there and
order but i'm curious to know how
you took away from the message on what
you can do to have your message become
more contagious
based on the strategies that he shared
with you comment below and if you've
never watched a video i did a couple
years ago explaining the difference
between marketing
and sales click over here to watch that
video and if you're not subscribed to
the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
[Music]